hello everyone and welcome to game four
of the opera euro rapid of the match
magnus carlson vs maxine vashir lagrav
this is the second match and maxime is
now leading so magnus now needs a win
uh to win the match completely and go
into the finals or
if maxine draws or wins this one then
they go into the tie break so let's see
what happens here as it's
quite uh quite interesting and quite
short so magnus with the white pieces
uh again goes for d4 now we have knight
to f6
c4 we have g6 knight to c3 and d5 again
we have the groomfield defense
uh we have captures captures and now
again magnus goes for the
bishop to d2 line we have bishop to g7
and now
e4 striking in the center uh we have
knight back to b6 we already uh
explained a few
videos ago why night captures and c3 is
not all that uh
favorable here so knight to b6 and as
now the
pawn is attacked twice you have to
defend it bishop the
bishop to e3 now the pawn is defended
twice uh we have
castles and magnus tries to get rid of
this knife from
uh b6 and he wants to push a5 so maxime
stops that pushes a5
himself and now h3 uh we have knight to
c6 and the knight to f3 and there is one
game in the database where
e5 was played but that's not all that
impressive is white really does gain a
lot of space with the d5
so instead after knight to f3 we have
knights to b4
and it is as a move tended we have a
completely new game so now maxine moves
the knight he wants to play c6 and uh
prevent the white from pushing the
central pawns
so bishop to e2 magnus is now ready to
castle and the c6
as planned we have castles and bishop to
e6
now it looks kind of weird because this
pawn is still on e7 but his real plan is
bishop to c4 and then to trade off the
light square bishops
and he will be left with two good
knights and a very nice dark square
bishop so here
knight the g5 by magnus going after this
bishop and just bishop the c4
as planned and here magnus plays rook to
c1
now you don't want to trade here because
you don't really gain anything but
so rook to c1 and now there is a lot of
pressure on this bishop
and the situation on the clock is seven
minutes for magnus and thirteen minutes
for maxine
so maxine uh very comfortable in this
position it seems that today he's fully
prepared for
everything magnus uh throws his way so
rook the c8
there's really no good way to exploit
this you can't really capture and then
open up a discovery somewhere
uh so instead b3 uh pushing back the
bishop uh or rather
bishop captures on e2 because you don't
really have a good square to go to and
if
let's say a6 then white just captures
and doubles your pawn so bishop captures
knight captures now the d4 pawn is
nicely defended and
knight to d7 now preparing to strike in
the center
uh with with moves like c5 maybe e5 is
an idea
later on so magnus goes for f4 and now
h6 pushing back the knight knight to f3
and now
e6 and here although it seems like you
can grab a lot of space with the g4 it
could be a bit too risky
and magnus although he wants to attack
he he he also wants to be solid so here
knight to e5 uh and now comes c5
uh maxine played the c5 more pretty
instantly he wants to attack white
center
and the dust weaken it so here we have
knight captures on d7
also possible was knight to c4 and the
knight has some excellent squares here
putting pressure on a5 and so on
and if knight to f6 now uh just e5 and
it's so it's a very interesting position
for white but by playing c5
maximum in fact gave magnus a pawn so
magnus just grabs it
knight captures queen captures and then
now comes d captures on c5 and now
the pawn is grabbed and maxime just
blockaged the pawn and makes room for
this room to enter the game and now
maxim sacrificed upon but he will get a
lot of activity
for it magnus goes e5 grabs more space
here and now rook f to d8 as planned
that the queen is under attack
and now comes knight to d4 and this is
already
quite quite a tricky move because bishop
to d4 is the way to go here bishop to b4
and then you have nothing to worry about
the bishop is nicely defended all of
this is defended
and if queen e4 or something like that
you can even play rook to c4
and everything holds however magnus
after rook after the eighth played
knight to d4
attacking maxime's queen and now maxine
just played queen e4
attacking uh uh magnus's bishop here and
now
uh magnus wanted to play queen to d2 to
defend the bishop and continue the game
and then
the game might continue in various ways
something like bishop here going after
the pawn or something like that
but magnus grabbed the queen with the
mouse of course as these are online
games and played queen to d3
and as soon as magnus played this he
also resigned the game
because this is now a free queen and now
the knight can just capture it so it was
in this position on the move 24 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game
and now they have to go into tie breaks
and maxine
is the winner of the second match so uh
this is something that
happens quite often in online chess
there's no way to
prevent this i know you guys gave a lot
of suggestions on how to counter these
uh
uh to give confirmations or something
like that but none of that works because
in in time
time trouble if you both players have a
few seconds on the clock there is no
time to play move and then confirm move
and then so on
so it's something that players will have
to get used to and uh
i don't know for the moment it seems
that we're stuck with the mouse slips
and
it will be a standard part of
of modern chess but magnus wasn't all
that uh
angry with this usually when magnus
loses the game or something he's going
to be very angry he might even throw
something but here
he just smiled and he thought it was
funny because uh
okay yeah he he didn't expect to
actually win this game because now his
position is worse even without
blundering the queen
uh but uh you know uh he he he will he
will take his chances
in the tie breaks so we'll see what
happens queen to d3
quite quite a move uh and of course uh
he resigned here
uh so yeah very very exciting stuff um
you know yeah
okay careful uh careful with with
the queen if you're playing with the
mouse uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh and by the looks of magnus he also
enjoyed it as he did not mind wandering
this queen he he really had a good laugh
about it
uh so we'll see what happens in the tie
breaks i would like to thank no deathman
louis burkhart david kimura harry lewin
and stephen hunt for your contribution
to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament probably with the tie
breaks
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day